MISS.
FIRST THE KNEW
FIRST THE KNE
FIRST THE NEE
FIRST THE NEW
FIRST THE NEW N
FIRST THE NEW NEW
FIRST THE NEW NEW K
FIRST THE NEW NEW KNO
FIRST THE NEW NEW KNOW
FIRST THE NEW NEW KNOW NO
FIRST THE NEW NEW KNOW NOTH
FIRST THE NEW NEW KNOW NOTHIN
FIRST THE NEW NEW KNOW NOTHING.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
THE DEMOCRATS PORTRAY THEMSELVES
AS MEMBERS OF THE ENLIGHTENED
NOTHING.
HE SHOOTS FROM THE HIP AND THE
MOUTH.
HE HASN'T MARRINATED HIMSELF IN
THE WRITINGS OF PLATO AND
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND GEO-POLITICS.
HE LACKS COMPASSION.
HE IS SO CRASS.
>> I THINK IT'S FAIR TO NOTE
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS VULGAR.
>> HE WATCHES A LOT OF CABLE
HIS LACK OF INTEREST IN READING
IS A BIG CONTRAST TO OUR LAST
TWO PRESIDENTS.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY EMPATHY
EVEN FOR HIS RECOVERY WIFE.
>> Laura: THE SAME LEFT WINGERS
ARE CONSPIRING TO MAKE OUR
CHILDREN MUCH WORSE.
NOT ONLY DO MANY LIBERALS HATE
OUR AMERICAN TRADITIONS AND HER
OUR AMERICAN TRADITIONS AND HE
HERITAGE BUT THEY ARE THE AGENTS
OF A HISTORICAL PURGE THE LIKES
OF WHICH WE HAVE NEVER SEEN.
THIS WEEK LEFTISTS  LIBRANNIAN
INCLUDES STEREOTYPICAL ATTITUDES
REGARDING THE DEPICTION OF THE
AVANATIS.
-- OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
DON'T WE WANT TO KNOW HOW PEOPLE
IN THE PAST LIVE AND FOUGHT AND
OUR HISTORY.
WHERE DO OUR CHILDREN GO DO
AS WELL.
WHO ARE THE REAL BOOK BANNERS
NOW?
WELL, THERE IS THE LOVELY
THE INSTRUCTION OF HISTORICAL
RATHER THAN ALLOWING THE NEXT
GENERATION TO SEE IT.
INTERPRET IT AND DEBATE IT.
ACTIVISTS TO TOPPLE OR DEFACE
STATUES THAT ARE PART OF OUR
NATURAL MEMORY.
I AM SAYING THIS AS A
CONNECTICUT YANKEE.
I HAVE NO AFFINITY FOR THE
SOUTH.
IT DOESN'T STOP THERE.
EVEN A CROSS MEMORIAL IN
MARYLAND IS CONSIDERED OFFENSIVE
TO ATHIESTS.
THEY FILED A SUIT TO HAVE IT
REMOVED AND THE 4th CIRCUIT
DEMOLITION.
WHO ARE THE INTOLERANT KNOW
NOTHINGS?
REFUSE TO ACCEPT EACH EVEN BASIC
FACTIONS.
-- FACTS.
ABORTION IS ONE EXAMPLE.
THIS IS AN ESTABLISHED
SCIENTIFIC FACT AND WE HAVE THE
PICTURES TO PROVE IT.
WHO CAN DENY AN ULTRA-SOUND OF A
12-WEEK OLD CHILD IN THE WOMB IS
GROUPS LIKE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AT
LARGE ARE DETERMINED TO LOOK THE
OTHER WAY.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE CAN SEE THIS.
THE VISUAL EVIDENCE, THE PROOF
OF LIFE IS A THREAT.
DON'T LOOK.
THE LEFT IS SO ANTI-DIALOGUE,
THEY PREFER TO INTIMIDATE THEIR
OPPONENTS RATHER THAN CONVINCE
THEM.
BRING THEM TO YOUR POINT OF
VIEW.
NO, THEY RESORT TO SLANDER OR
TRUMP SUPPORTERS AS DEPLORABLE
CLINGING TO GUNS AND RELIGIONS.
WE TOLD YOU ABOUT THE TEXTS FROM
THE FBI AGENCY WORKING ON THE
HILLARY CLINTON PROBE.
THEY SAID TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE
UNEDUCATED AND LAZY AND THINK HE
WILL GRANT THEM JOBS FOR DOING
NOTHING.
THE WHITE HOUSE SOMEONE WHO
COULD LEAD THE KU KLUX KLAN IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
SOMEBODY WHO COULD BE THE LEADER
OF THE NEO NAZIS.
>> IF YOU VOTED FOR TRUMP, THEN
LIKE NAZIS GOING YOU HERE AND
YOU HERE.
>> TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
VOTED FOR HIM AFTER HE SHOWED
HIS CARDS.
>> ARE YOU SUGGESTING THEY ARE
RACIST?
>> YES.
>> ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED
>> Laura: AT LEAST THEY ARE
BEING HONEST NOW.
BY CASTING THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS AS SUB-HUMAN CLASS,
THE LEFT HAS A BLANKET LICENSE
TO ATTACK THEM AND TARGET THEM
IN PUBLIC.
>> THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO GO TO A
RESTAURANT.
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO STOP AT A
THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TURN ON
THEM.
THEY ARE GOING TO PROTEST AND
HARASS THEM UNTIL THEY DECIDE
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT NO, I CAN'T HANG WITH
YOU.
>> Laura: HARASS THEM IN PUBLIC
PLACES.
THE LEFTIST RENEGADES ABSORBED
THIS MESSAGE.
IT'S OPEN SEASON ON REPUBLICANS.
THERE ARE WANTED POSTERS WITH
MILLER'S IMAGE!
WANTED POVERTY.
-- POSTERS.
TO BE HUNTED AND CAPTURED.
JUSTIFYED IN THEIR MIND.
FOR MONTH THE LEFT INSISTED THAT
THE TRAVEL BAN WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THEY DERIDED TRUMP AS RACIST FOR
ATTEMPTING TO PROHIBIT TRAVEL
FROM HOT SPOTS THAT OBAMA TARGET
FROM HOT SPOTS THAT OBAMA TARG T
TARGETED TOO.
WE CAN'T VET THESE PEOPLE.
NO SYSTEM IS IN PLACE.
THE COURT TODAY WEIGHED IN, WANT
RULING THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
IMMIGRATION, BUT THAT THE BAN
DIDN'T CONTAIN ANY RELIGIOUS OR
ANTI-MUSLIM BIAS.
>> THE RULING SHOWS THAT ALL OF
THE ATTACKS FROM THE MEDIA AND
THE DEMOCRATS AND POLITICIANS
ARE WRONG AND THEY TURNED OUT TO
BE VERY WRONG.
WITH TRUMP ON THE TRAVEL BAN.
THE DNC DEPUTY CHAIR WITHOUT
EVEN AN ATTEMPT AT A REFERENCE
TO INTERPRETATION, HE REACTED
THIS WAY.
>> GORSUCH SHOULD NOT BE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
HE IS NOT THERE PROPERLY.
YOU CAN DO THAT.
YOU CAN JAM IN A SUPREME COURT
BY DENYING A SITTING PRESIDENT
THEIR RIGHT TO APPOINT THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
GORSUCH HAS DONE WHAT HE WAS
SENT THERE TO DO.
JUST DOING WHAT HIS PAY MASTER
A JURORIST ON THE FEDERAL COURT
NO ATTEMPT AT A RATIONAL
ARGUMENT.
JUST PERSONAL DEMONIZATION OF A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
TODAY, WE ARE SEEING THE RISE OF
UP OF SECRET FORCES.
THEY KNOW NOTHING OF IMPACTS.
-- FACTS.
NOTHING OF HISTORY AND NOTHING
OF THE DAMAGE THEY ARE DOING NOW
TO THE REPUBLICAN.